There are a lot of people in the press.
And I know you would agree with us that have really abused their position of
power. And it is a position of power.
I will never forget the story of this elderly lady.
And I wrote about it in my book, uh,
this elderly woman who had a Facebook group,
that was a pro-Trump Facebook group. I mean, you know,
she can do whatever she wants. She can play Farmville.
She can do a pro-Trump Facebook group. And, um,
CNN showed up at her house and they did on her there.
Her address was displayed on camera and she ended up getting threats.
And I'm, I I'm thinking what, because you don't like her political affiliation,
you decide to abuse your authority as a way to really intimidate people
into not engaging in a right. That they have,
that that's bothersome.
Let's talk about the press a little bit sort of main stream. Um,
everyone's watching it collapse. Everyone's watching, you know,
the quote unquote journalist destroy journalism. Um,
does this thing just need to flame out, uh, you know,
if you would have asked me maybe six months ago, I was still on the, Oh,
this thing can be fixed wagon or at least that we should still be trying to
fix it. And now after Corona, I'm just like,
and after what Chuck Todd did, uh, in the last couple of weeks with, uh,
with Bob BARR and just like watching the rest of it, it's like, you know what,
maybe just let it crumble.
And while I think there's major risks on the other side,
if we have nothing that's mainstream, it's like,
what gives us national cohesion? It's like, why are we saving this thing?
Or are you in that space?
Or do you think that there's something worth saving or somewhat so mixed? Maybe.
It's kind of a mix.
I don't ever think that the press has been unbiased ever even since its
inception. I mean, I think of the funny little ways that they used to,
like during the days of our founding, that the, uh,
that folks would go after each other, politicians would write nasty editorials,
which were so much more scandalous than some of the stuff that we see.
I mean that.
You got syphilis, like a whole bunch of stuff. Yeah.
Colonial Housewives come to life. That's what it seemed like.
It was crazy. Uh, I don't think that they've ever been unbiased.
I do think that they maybe perhaps have been a little bit more attentive to the
needs of the people because at one point the press was the people, the press,
and the people kind of were hand in hand and the press was the people's way to
keep check on their government.
And now it's dissolved into party allegiances and a lot of the
press, and there have been surveys.
The majority of them identify politically one way as opposed to the other.
And I don't even have a problem with that.
The problem that I have is the egos of so many of these individuals who seem to
think that the byline is the most important thing on a piece,
as opposed to the information that the piece is sharing and or supposed to
share.
And so many of these Q A's with the president turned into some kind of
footage for a reporter to, uh, aggrandized themselves and,
and make a story out of themselves. Or it's all prop it's, you know,
political propaganda. And it's, it's frustrating because I always feel, uh,
you know,
a free press is a sacred thing and I will defend that to the
end, but are they free though,
when they cannot report on things outside of that, that political filter,
when everything has to run through that party affiliation is that really free
reporting.
And I also think that criticism of the press seems to be taboo now,
but a lot of people in the press don't seem to understand that a free press and
a free people's right to criticize their free press.
These are things that go hand in hand. You can't have one without the other,
and you can't criticize our criticism of you without kind of ultimately what
betraying your principles. So I wish I don't, like I said,
I don't mind bias when it's honest,
but I don't want people to report something and have it be politically,
you know, one cited and then try to rely on the credit earned by a previous
media generation back when they at least attempted to not place so much emphasis
on the byline or who was anchoring the news at that particular point. And,
and really just,
I wish that they would just focus on the information and if they want to do
editorial do editorial, like I'm not a journalist. I, I'm not a hard,
I'm not a hard reporter. I am an, editorialist an analyst.
I, I am so biased. It's crazy,
but I admit it and I'll be honest with people about it, but just, just, just,
I want them to do the same as well. Just be honest about it.
I think people get confused when people attack the media.
There seems to be this idea that if people like you and I attack the media,
that somehow we're part of the problem or the other version of this is like,
when, when Trump fights with everyone at CNN,
he's fighting with Jim Acosta and people are like, he's attacking the press.
And it's like, well, I actually have no problem with that.
He has first amendment rights to now,
if he was using the power of the government, obviously to silence them, well,
now we got a problem. Um, but he, as far as I know, he's not doing that yet.
They love to play the victim too. And it's like,
what happens in America constantly is that everyone is exercising their free
speech all the time. I mean, we could get to the big tech problem,
maybe in a moment, but like that, the way it actually is working,
Trump fighting with them, them attacking Trump, us attacking them.
You may not love the whole game. And it may be,
it may be something that burns too hot, you know?
So it's eventually going to explode or something,
but like everyone's free speech is being, you know, protected basically.
No, I think that's a good point. I mean, isn't that,
isn't that what it's all about? I mean,
America has always been kind of like a big giant family arguing at the dinner
table and it makes it infuriating, but also amazing. I mean,
I wouldn't change it for the world. That's what it's supposed to be like.
But this idea that you're, you know,
if you criticize or the press for bad reporting,
and there are numerous examples of bad reporting,
there are entire media entities on the right that exists to document
legitimate cases of biased reporting.
And that that's not attacking anyone. They act like they're on a battlefield.
And as they're trying to eat their MRE, they're, you know,
being hit with missiles from the president or from a Republican or whatever,
because they dared to write a bad story. I mean there, and that's,
that's the point of it. We it's like we also,
in addition to keeping our politicians honest, we have to keep our press honest.
And I feel like we were sold a bill that was a bad sale.
Like we were supposed to have them as an ally instead of now,
because they had really, there are a lot of people in the press.
And I know you would agree with us that have really abused their position of
power. And it is a position of power.
I will never forget the story of this elderly lady.
And I wrote about it in my book, uh,
this elderly woman who had a Facebook group that was a pro-Trump Facebook group.
I mean, you know, she can do whatever she wants. She can play Farmville.
She can do a pro-Trump Facebook group. And, um,
CNN showed up at her house and they did on her there,
her address was displayed on camera and she ended up getting threats.
And I'm, I I'm thinking what, because you don't like her political affiliation,
you decide to abuse your authority as a way to really intimidate people
into not engaging in a right, that they have,
that that's bothersome. You know, I've been the victim of press bias.
You've been the victim of press bias.
I don't think there's anyone that is in this industry that hasn't been affected.
Um, but the idea that any kind of criticism of them means that they are being
persecuted. I would have to say, well, you know, there,
there is a definitive history as to who re who, who started what,
and it wasn't the people who attacked, uh, by, uh, an unbiased price.
It was the people who started pointing out some really unfair and nasty articles
that had been written. So I don't give a lot of credence to,
and when they're unfairly attacked, I'll definitely speak up,
but not every one of those attacks are unfair or criticisms are unfair.
So that's actually a perfect segue to the outrage part of this.
So as I'm doing all my press for my book,
one of the things that people are asking me constantly is when did the
outrage thing start? Is there a moment that you can point to that it started,
I have a couple of different answers for it.
Cause I think there's a few things that led up to it. Um,
but do you see like a moment or a political movement or a person that
sort of got us into this mess that now we all see.
Ooh,
that's a good question because it feels like people have been outraged for so
long, even since the, you know, George W. Bush years, even,
maybe even going back to Reagan. People have been outraged for a long time.
I remember going the first time I was ever at the Reagan library and I was
looking at, at one of the exhibits,
it was about some of the media bias towards Reagan and those headlines were
nasty. And he would say one thing or look one particular way.
And there were headlines about it.
I do think that it's grown to include almost every aspect of life.
So it's it's instead of it just being a reaction, it's now a culture.
And when that occurred, I, I, I don't know,
maybe sometime after George W. Bush,
it's one of those things where it's been around for so long,
we don't realize that we are in it. We haven't,
we don't realize how long we've been in it. I, when do you think it started?
So I, I have a couple of different answers on this, but I think, you know,
as you know, my story, so as a lefty,
I was very much in like the progressive thing.
And I think it was sort of the first time Bernie came around,
he ignited, although I don't think he himself was realizing what he was doing.
Exactly. He ignited this like thing that was laying underneath this, like,
like there was Tinder basically underneath that he ignited that sort of
everything in America was bad. And that once you do that,
you couple that with identity politics, you couple that with,
you know, 20 years or almost three decades,
maybe of kids being told that they can never lose and their feelings matter and
participation trophies,
and basically all of these things that then as we became more
hyper-partisan and then you finally, you throw Trump onto it,
which I think he was just a symptom of it, not the cause of it,
but that I think is why the last five years. Oh.
And then of course you throw social media into it.
So I don't know that there's an exact moment, but it was like,
it was like partisan.
Leftiness coupled with sort of the collapse of the decent liberal you throw
in social media, you throw in trolls, you throw in bots,
you throw in Trump who wants to play that game.
You throw in the dishonest media. And we just, it was like, we,
it was almost like we summoned this thing. We all sort of did it together.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our media playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.